في ظل الجدل القائم حول تهديدات محتمله
باستهداف برنامج ايران النووي بهجمات
الكترونيه تؤكد مصادر في طهران تعرض احدى
منشات تخصيب اليورانيوم في الايام الاخيره
لهجمات بفيروس يدعى ستاكس نت حيث القت
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه بمسؤوليه تلك الهجمات
على الولايات المتحده واسرائيل الامر الذي
جعل برنامجها النووي يتراجع عاما على
الاقل الى الوراء بحسب المراقبين وتبذل
طهران جهودا حثيثه للتصدي لتلك الهجمات
حيث قال مسؤول ايران ان بلاده ستطور شبكه
انترنت عسكريه منفصله خاصه بالجمهوريه
الاسلاميه ما كانوا يخططون للقيام به في
الاساس هو خادم مركزي هنا في طهران بحيث
يربط بعد ذلك كل المرافق النوويه وجميع
المنشات العسكريه بعضها ببعض على طول
الطريق في هذا الجزء الجنوبي الشرقي من
البلاد وقد علمت شبكه سي ان ان ان ايران
تطور بالفعل نسخه مدنيه من تلك الشبكه
وبينما يعتزم كولين اندرسون نشر التقرير
عن تلك الشبكات في الاسابيع المقبله يقول
الباحث المستقل الذي رفض الظهور امام عدسه
الكاميرا انه اكتشف مؤخرا نشاطا غير عادي
في بعض المواقع النوويه الايرانيه
المنفصله عن شبكه الانترنت العالميه
ويعتقد اندرسون ان الايرانيين يريدون ان
يعززوا قدراتهم على قطع الانترنت في حاله
تعرض لهجوم كما يؤكد انه في الوقت الراهن
يمكن لشبكه الانترنت الايرانيه الداخليه
ان تتصل مع الشركات والوزارات الحكوميه
فقط هل هذا هو السبب الوحيد لفعلهم ذلك
انهم يفعلون ذلك للسيطره على سكانهم في كل
مكان وهذا سيغطي كافه الجوانب المختلفه من
الاتصالات الاجتماعيه على الانترنت في
ايران ويؤكد اندرسون ان الحكومه الايرانيه
يمكنها وعبر الشبكات الانترنت الخاصه بها
قراءه اي مراسلات قادمه او
خارجه